flames and panic in the largest refugee
camp in the world
more than a million rohingya refugees
from myanmar live in cox's bazar
their shelters are flimsy and closely
packed the fire started
on monday afternoon and spread fast
oh brother i don't have any idea where
my wife and children are
o la where are my wife and children i'm
alone now i was unable to salvage
anything from my home
thousands of shelters were reportedly
destroyed in the blaze
at least 20 000 people fled for their
lives
as black smoke billowed overhead people
scrambled to save their belongings and
gather
their families i can't find my children
or
even my husband the name of one child is
moon and another
is rubia and my husband's name is
anumaji
it's not known what started the blaze
one witness told the news agency agents
france press that the fire spread faster
after gas cylinders used for cooking
exploded maybe more than a thousand
shelters have burnt down
many people have died elderly people
were unable to get out of the shelters
firefighters worked into the night
since we reached here we have been
trying to put the fire out
we are trying to extinguish the many
burning gas cylinders
most of the rohingya arrived in the camp
in 2017 during a crackdown by the
myanmar government
that the un called textbook ethnic
cleansing
the rohingya have suffered persecution
and been denied citizenship by
governments in myanmar
for decades they are often called the
world's
largest group of stateless people
this fire in the place they fled to for
safety
is a reminder of how difficult their
lives are and how tenuous their survival
can often be charles stratford al
jazeera